[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ramsey personality george
campbell is my co-host today as we take
your questions about your relationships
your work you your money and how these
things all are intertwined it's called
the ramsay show and life happens here
all the time starting this segment off
one of our good friends over in san
francisco micro from dirty jobs hey mike
what's up man
well dave i'm living the dream merry
christmas
yeah merry christmas to you
so you're getting ready to launch a
whole new set of dirty jobs i saw the
discoveries picked it up it's going big
again huh
well just when i thought i was out they
uh they pulled me back in after 10 years
we've got a new season coming out and uh
yeah it's hard to believe man a decade
ago i swore i was done you know we shot
300 of these things and filmed in every
state
but uh the lockdowns the talk of
essential workers
a lot of people wrote in to say you know
would be fun to see uh see what work
looks like again out there in the real
world through the eyes of an apprentice
uh how could i say no
yeah
well i mean
it's it is kind of a psychological
disaster that we declared people not
essential
it's a little bit humorous too when you
indicate it indicates how stupid the
government is
but uh
humorous in the way you laugh you know
when you fall down the stairs right i
mean it's just
yeah exactly it's like when you back
oh god
oh
something else something else well we
wanted to tell you uh tell folks that
the
series is back out it's on discovery
right
it is it'll be um right where i left it
actually uh sunday i think january 2nd 8
o'clock and then they got their
discovery plus thing and uh it'll be
over there too but yeah that's the plan
yeah the trailer looks um as always
interesting good trailer any teases mike
that you can give us was there one that
you're like i'll never do that again you
can't pay me enough money
you know i mean looking back
i'd say probably half of the 300 we did
i sort of checked in terms of not like a
bucket list but just like okay i'm glad
i did it i won't be doing it again uh
this season's not much different you
know remember i'm not the uh i'm not the
expert on the show i'm not even the host
really i'm i'm more like a guest
and the goal
really hasn't changed it's a an attempt
to give folks an honest look at a day's
work through the eyes of an apprentice
so when you don't really know what
you're doing
and you show up cold
uh you make a lot of mistakes but it's
in those mistakes that people can see
just how challenging how important and
how difficult the work can be
when you see somebody who knows what
they're doing getting the job done next
to me well
hey thanks for appearing on the
borrowed future documentary it has been
a big hit we've had over 150 000 folks
view it on uh google on google play and
apple tv and prime video amazon prime
and uh i think we really stirred up a
ruckus together and we appreciate you
participating in that hey look like i
told you the first time we spoke dave
the only four-letter word that was
really off-limits in my house growing up
was debt
and when i see what's happened to so
many people today kids and grown-ups
what is it now 1.7 trillion dollars in
student loans
on the books
and now we've got looks like close to 11
million
open positions that that don't require a
four-year degree it's just mind-boggling
that we're telling the same generation
again and again that the best path for
the most people
is the most expensive path and um we
need more
content like the stuff you guys are
churning out and i was i was privileged
uh to be a part of it thank you well we
we appreciate it folks be sure you tune
in uh sharon and i have got a whole list
of things we're going to try to watch
through the holidays y'all probably like
that too and you can just put borrowed
future on there if you want to learn the
truth about the whole student loan
debacle and george you were square in
the middle of that as well oh yeah when
we did the podcast which was the
precursor to this and mike was nice
enough to let us use a clip and he
shares this incredible story uh back
when he was in school and what those
teachers told him and your clips mike
are some of my favorites in there
because you just go oh finally someone
with a head on their shoulders who's
who's saying the truth and so it's just
so refreshing to hear uh voices like
yours speak to those young people and
say there's a different path it doesn't
have to be this way it doesn't have to
end with two hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt and then i open my
email and i find out that my work two
worlds have collided my buddy john rich
my buddy mike rowe get together and do a
song which little known little known
fact about you you're a big time singer
i mean like broadway professionally
trained yeah before opera singer before
you were uh doing dirty jobs and so
you and john hook up and did a song
which has become the number one song in
the u.s and i'm not exaggerating you
bumped what christine aguilera or
whatever off the chart right off the off
the top slot with this song and and
i gotta tell you it's a lot of fun but
the fact that it's number one is a
little ridiculous
it's preposterous dave and look it's
just one of those life lessons you know
you can sit down with your idea and your
hopes and your dreams and you can work
on whether it's a book or a tv show and
maybe people like it they probably won't
right and then one day you walk into a
bathroom with a knucklehead and a cowboy
hat and you're right santa claus got a
dirty job and you record it the oakridge
boys come in and the next thing you know
you're at the top of the charts so
you know you can plan
all you want but so much of the good
stuff that's happened to me in life has
happened because
i throw a lot of mud against the wall
and i'm never quite sure what's going to
stick
but this crazy song you know john's
given his half of the money to folds of
honor which is a great charity that he's
been supporting for years and i've given
my half to microworks which goes right
to the student debt crisis and so i
think between the time of the year
the fact that it was all for charity
and the fact that a guy in a baseball
cap and a cowboy
hat wrote the song in a bathroom
basically on a dare i mean how do you
say no to that yeah well apparently
people aren't because they're lining up
for it so i i had dinner with my wife
and i had dinner with john and his wife
the other night and uh we were laughing
all the way through dinner that this
thing
i mean john has written probably what a
thousand songs or something um he's had
quite a few number ones and a lot of
people don't even realize he's as
prolific a writer as he is because he's
an artist but
from big and rich and fame and so forth
but and then pulling the oak ridge boys
in that was genius
well
the thing is you know first and foremost
john's a patriot and
you know i realized that he was
interviewing me for his show on fox
business when we started singing songs
to each other that's what started this
whole thing
and um you know i've always been a big
proponent that uh way leads on to way
and you know you got to play the cards
that you get and john just happened to
have the oak ridge boys in his rolodex
and um you know it's funny too dave the
first time i met you
i think i spoke at one of your things
and larry gatlin was in the audience
yeah and uh
he and i have stayed in touch
so worlds collide man like you say you
really never know
thank you brother we appreciate you
hanging out crank this thing up as a
bump music out of this break and uh
check out mike rowe
dirty jobs comes out january 2nd
speaking out for 24 hours straight gotta
out run and pick our dogs gotta do
whatever it takes don't you know that's
sad
santa
claus
santa claus got a dirty job
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five
five two two five
our thanks to mike rowe for uh coming on
hanging out with us for a little bit
he's a busy dude
and uh we appreciate him participating
in the borrowed future documentary again
put the borrowed future documentary on
your list of things to watch through the
holidays
um it is the uh
full rundown on uh
truly how student loans are killing the
american dream
yeah and if you want to skip a hallmark
movie this is the one to watch right
here 88 minutes and it'll help you avoid
some awkward holiday conversations with
the family and instead this documentary
will spark conversation i will say that
it is stirring up a holy ruckus and i
love what we're hearing in just the
feedback of saying wow this has given me
a way to talk to my kids in a way that i
could never have on my own so i love
what this might do for the future of
america well it's waking parents up
to not
and not participate in their kids
falling for
this ridiculous epic failure called the
student loan system
it is abusive it's out of control
it's in bad shape and it's leaving
people
in a mess yeah and february 1st student
loans are getting turned back on i think
it's going to rile up people once again
to get angry about this whole situation
get angry at their debt hopefully we see
a lot of people get aggressive and pay
it off but i'm hoping this documentary
gets another spark as we head into that
season of people going oh my gosh sally
mae's back
well merry christmas america we're glad
you're with us open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
tasha's in pennsylvania hey tasha what's
up
hi dave i need help we'll try how can we
help
so here's the situation i recently
bought a primary residence
i have a rental property
that i've owned since 2013 it used to be
my primary
but this new home that i bought is
turning out to be a bit of a money pit
and i need
cash to help do renovations on it
i'm hesitant to sell my rental but i
know that if i do i could be debt-free
but i'm not sure if that's the right
choice because i do make money on it
i also have 47 000 in student loans
so i've got debt i've got equity and i'm
just kind of frozen and i don't know
what to do
[Music]
well i yeah if you can sell the rental
and have the cash to finish the money
pit and not be a money pit anymore and
have the cash to knock out your student
loans then i'm selling it
uh the question i've got is are you
going down a rabbit hole with this money
pit thing and you need to sell it
it's something i thought about
but in its current state i would be
losing
tens of thousands of dollars
so i don't remember you tore it up after
you bought it
so
i bought it knowing it was a fixer-upper
thinking it was going to be cosmetic but
once i started taking some things down i
discovered some serious structural
issues
so there's no equity in the house and to
sell it as it stands
i probably won't even recoup you know
what little i've done so
what'd you pay for it
i paid 96. what would it sell for today
as always so for today as is
i mean i think 50 60 tops
okay so i would be losing upwards of 30
to 40 000 right off the bat
i think either way needs about 50k in
work too and then at that point what
would it be worth if you put all this
money into it are you going to recoup it
i would anyway i would have no equity
but i think i would break even if i put
in 50 i think it would be worth around
130 140. so i'd probably break even no
equity and i'd have a nice home to live
in and you'd be happy with the home at
that point
i would i would yeah it's just a matter
of funding those
repairs and
i'm hesitant to sell the rental i could
do a cash out refi
and have money to do it i know that's
probably not dave's choice um but well
you've got all this interesting you've
got a pile of debt too sitting there
with a student loan so i like the idea
of paying off the of selling the rental
could you pay off your student loans and
have a pile of cash if you sold the
rental
so my rental i bought in 2013 for 150.
i only owe 104.
and in this market it's probably worth
350.
i could be debt-free i could pay off the
mortgage on the new house with it
i could be totally debt-free if i sold
it
i like the sound of your voice even
saying that sounds like this anxiety is
not worth the money coming in from the
rental you could clean up the student
loan debt have a pile of money and have
some money to fix your primary residence
that sounds like that's what i would do
if i was in your shoes
yeah because it sounds like this is just
not a fun time for you right now as is
it's not
and on the rental i net about 700 a
month
um so it's
i feel like it's decent but
it could also solve all my problems if i
got rid of it yeah
i think that's the answer that that last
sentence that's what sums it up right
and um
you know basically this bad decision
has forced you into a corner
on which next decision you make and you
don't want it to be a bad decision
so
you know if you don't want to lose
thirty thousand dollars selling
the house as is
and move on with your life and keep the
rental
then um then i would sell the rental and
i'd finish fixing this place up i'm a
little bit afraid that it's more than
50k for you to fix it up but you're
gonna have more than 50k so that's okay
here's what's interesting
when you're doing the fix up with cash
from the rental
that you kind of are pissed about having
to sell it
you're going to be super careful
with the renovation and you're not going
to go overboard because you're using
like real money that came from a source
that you didn't really want to have to
do
and so it's going to kind of make you
very very wise
in your renovation process and and
you'll be a lot calmer in your
innovation process too because you're
not doing it all with borrowed money the
chances you do a cash out refi and then
let's let's just add to this equation a
bunch of debt
let's add to this mess a big pile of
debt
no that would just be you're just
compounding the stupid then
and no i wouldn't do that but yes i'd
sell your rental here and let's get this
mess cleaned up get the get the mortgage
paid off get the rental fixed or get the
house fixed up and
get the uh uh
get student loan paid off and you got a
lot of peace in your life at that point
ah kate's with us in ontario hi kate how
are you
hi gabe i'm great thank you so much for
taking my call today sure what's up
well um my very dear grandmother has
recently passed away and i found out i'm
going to be inheriting between 150 and
200 000 canadian dollars
and my husband and i are recently debt
free in the last two weeks wow
so i'm just looking to see how
how we should proceed with this really
wonderful gift from her
so are you guys in baby step three now
are you saving up for that fully funded
emergency fund
uh yes we are well that's two thousand
dollars in savings okay well we can
check that box off and once you've got
that three to six months um you guys
will start investing and that can just
come out of your your income that
doesn't have to be part of this
inheritance and we're moving on do you
guys have kids
no we don't that's that's not the cards
for us and you have a primary residence
with a mortgage on it
uh yes we have about 168 000 left on our
mortgage this sounds like you could be
in baby step 7 instantly fully funded
emergency fund and a paid for house
thanks to graham wow
yes that's a
huge gift from her in canada we
have different investing options should
i be considering putting
25 000 of this in a tax sheltered
investment account i can do that and it
would reduce my taxable income for the
upcoming tax year only if that means
doesn't mean you can't pay off your
house if you can pay if you can't pay
off your house by doing that then no you
need to pay off the house
okay so the the priorities are fully
fund the emergency fund the remaining
and pay off i'll get in there
and pay off
yeah if there's money left after that
then we can get to tinkering because
you're baby step seven then we'll get to
tinkering with your investment options
and your retirement options and all that
kind of stuff but
now let's get that house done girl and
you gotta know that grandma's smiling
i mean she's in heaven looking at this
going they just paid off their house
that's pretty cool
and by the way you're on a budget and
you're taking what used to be a house
payment you're investing it and you'll
be a baby steps millionaire in no time
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five jamie and cara are with us
in portland oregon says on my screen you
guys are debt free congratulations
oh thank you so much thank you well done
well done how much have you paid off
uh just under 250 000
wow how long did that take
five years five years and your range of
income during that time
we actually uh started at around 50 and
um this year we're expecting to come in
at 150. oh good what do y'all do for a
living
well i had a change in careers at the
moment i'm doing uh several things
anywhere from data analysis and
information security to uh
to uh keeping bees on top of rooftops
that works for me good
so uh what about you kara
oh i actually changed careers as well i
started out in
higher education and now i'm a financial
analyst for a technology company oh good
cool
cool wow what kind of debt was the 250
000
it was everything
uh we had about 5 800 in like personal
family loans
uh 35 000 in a small business which are
loans which are actually also personal
loans um
i had about 32 000 in student loans and
you yeah about 90 000 by the time uh
sallie mae was kicked out of the uh the
bedroom hmm
okay uh what else do we have and then we
had a 90 000 was actually a small
mortgage we also had
on your current residence or
no past residence uh manufactured home
actually oh had to clean up a mess back
there so you still have your mortgage
yes so you're debt-free everything with
the mortgage way to go
yeah uh we're gonna uh we actually just
moved to portland oregon from uh from
arizona
arizona it was a um
one of our dreams that we wanted to to
move up here but as you say a lot you
don't get a pass on math in higher cost
of living areas so we knew we had to get
rid of our debt
in order to to make this move and to you
know accomplish a lot of our goals so
that's what we did wow that's awesome
we're so proud of you guys so take us
back five years ago what happened where
you went all right we got a quarter of a
million dollars in debt sitting here we
got to clean this up
uh well that's a pretty good uh story
there i'll try to keep it short um
uh we basically we were we had a couple
kids we had one on the way um at the
very beginning of this and
weren't uh i wasn't too sure of how we
were going to
move forward and provide some security
uh for the one on the way um started out
by just uh looking into uh life
insurance
um
and i was driving on the road and
visiting various businesses for
something i was doing at the time
and listening to a lot of dave ramsey so
that's how the conversation actually
started was hey we got kid on the way
how about insurance
and uh one thing led to another and uh
we took it from there wow not every day
hear a story start with well i was
looking for insurance and here we are
debt-free
that's incredible so what was the
journey like for you guys when you're
throwing 50k a year at this thing what
were the sacrifices you made along the
way
um
not eating out i guess was was one of
them um just kind of saying making the
decision to evaluate
uh
do we actually need this thing
now or can it wait um
we
were running a farm at the time that was
one of the my my business and so um
although it was flexible it was taking
on some debt so we decided no more debt
as far as taking on business debt we're
going to cash flow everything and start
hacking away at the debt that that we
did have wow for the business you
stopped the bleeding and cut some
expenses and just buckled down for five
years yeah wow immediately yep
way to go guys proud of you guys how's
it feel now that you're free
it's amazing
yeah yeah it's a lot uh we wouldn't have
been able to make the move up here
actually um there's so much to do up
here that it would have just been a
disaster because
um especially you know a lot of people
here complain about the rain and the
cold but it's a different you have a
different outlook and perspective on
wherever you're at if you don't have you
know a big ball and chain of debt it's
always sunny when you're debt free
there you go
i love it
way to go you guys well we're very very
proud of you congratulations we're going
to send you a copy of the new book baby
steps millionaires want that to be the
next chapter in your story how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth how
you can too
comes out january the 11th but we're
going to send you your advanced copy now
and also a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody and get them started on their
journey as well okay
thank you thank you well merry christmas
you guys we appreciate you calling in
very very cool jamie and cara portland
oregon
250 000
paid off over five years
quite a journey changed their whole life
their location and everything making 50
to 150 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three
two
one
well done boys and girls i love it
excellent excellent job
jacob is with us in chattanooga hi jacob
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave and george can you hear me all
right absolutely how can we help
thank you and look forward to being with
you on january 13th in nashville as well
cool i'm glad you're coming yeah
yeah thank you uh real estate question
i'm wondering what would be the best way
to get
a property a house into my daughter's
name
that we own
is there a mortgage on it
yes there is
okay are you going to pay that off
well
uh
eventually it will be paid off it's only
14-year fixed at the moment
about a little over three percent
interest yeah here's the loan with
investment property
uh it is with tvscu
credit federal credit okay yes credit
key all right here's the thing this the
if they used a boilerplate standard deed
of trust which they probably did in
tennessee
um it has a due on sale
provision and it's usually paragraph 17
oddly enough i'm such a nerd i know that
so look at paragraph 17 on your deed and
you'll see a standard fannie mae boiler
plate okay but either way it it
almost all deeds today
almost all mortgages today state that if
the property is transferred
the loan is called due in full instantly
and so you cannot transfer the property
title to her unless you make
arrangements on this mortgage well if
you took her down to the credit union
would they qualify her for the mortgage
no
that was the original problem
okay why
uh
we raised our kids to be you know
financial peace babies and uh
and so she is 22 years old she owns her
own business
uh has has a pretty good savings
and uh but
but at 22 and recently having bought
this house and moved out of our house
she never had any credit established nor
did she have any trade lines established
how have she been in the house she was
able to qualify
uh we closed in september she moved
right in so
she's not been in there long enough to
establish trade lines now
and her job is her is self-employed and
so she's gonna have to have two years of
tax returns that show enough income
to qualify yes
and she doesn't show enough income to
qualify you can't put the house in her
name
okay unless you pay it off
i see
yeah and uh and that was that was the
other dilemma
should
we uh
you know we had been on
baby step seven and
but we have you know we're uh
ramsay millionaires now but uh
but most of it's in retirement accounts
so how old are you
i'm 49. okay how much is out on this
house
[Music]
about 165 yeah i'd sell it and put her
in a rental let her go rent something
let her start her life
no reason for her to be saddled with 165
000 debt at 25 years 22 years old
i'd move on dude
[Music]
well we all know the story of the
tortoise and the hair and we all know
who wins in the end
but we often gloss over the downfall
of the hair
he didn't lose because he was slower he
lost because he took a nap he took his
eye off the prize
he quit being goal oriented
and if you start to lose if you're
starting to lose steam this is your wake
up call we want 2022 to be your best
wealth building year ever
for just a few more days we've got all
kinds of life changing books and tools
in our famous ten dollar sale these ten
dollar books could be your best biggest
investment
get books like the number one bestseller
the total money makeover eight million
people have read that
dr john deloney's quick read redefining
anxiety also ten bucks rachel cruz's new
york times bestseller from just a little
bit earlier in the year know yourself
know your money also just 10 bucks
there's something for everyone make 2022
your best wealth building year yet shop
the 10 sale before it ends at
ramseysolutions.com
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jackson is with
us in atlanta hi jackson welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave um thanks for taking my call i'm
18 years old and i'm part owner of a
family business and we're taking on some
part-time employees
um
we're also growing quite a bit and we're
looking into getting some heavy
machinery that's going to help us with
the process we think
and i was wondering if you could uh help
me know what's the best decision here to
do
i'm sorry i don't know what your best
decision on what is this a financial
question or is this more about the
business in general
yeah so
basically we want to know
um whether we should buy this machinery
it's a cnc machine
and it would make the process it would
make it a lot easier and it would cut
down on the
man hours quite a bit but um it also
costs a lot of money like we're looking
five or six thousand dollars
and uh last year we netted about um 100
000 i think it was and um
so yeah we're just wondering is this
really cost effective
well
i would look at it in terms of first of
all obviously you're gonna pay cash for
this right
yes we're not gonna go into debt and
second of all if you look at you know
what are you going to recoup by getting
this machine is this machine going to
make you
six thousand dollars in the first few
months
[Music]
no probably not
probably it would be more long-term this
would be a year or two product
development okay um
yeah something like that
well in business we don't buy
anything for fun
in business we buy things that give us
more money than they cost back a return
on investments what we're always looking
for
so if the machine you spend five
thousand dollars on it will make you
back five more than five thousand
dollars in a reasonable period of time
in your mind
then that's an investment in the
business and you're paying cash for it
and yes i would do that
if it's just like
uh a boy's excuse to get some toys
which sometimes boys use their business
as an excuse to get some toys
i might be guilty of having done that in
the past
um
and uh you know the budget's real tight
at home but we had to have this one for
business baby so uh you know i mean if
it's stuff like that then no we don't do
that
um and so
you know we we're always looking for
in business you should you should never
have expenses you should just have
investments
so everything that you're putting out
you're doing to cause your business to
grow
and that's an investment sometimes it
saves expenses
uh or same saves cost it's a cost
savings mechanism it sounds like this
will save some labor maybe you want to
hire me people so if we spend 6000 here
it keeps us from having our five
thousand here keeps us from spending ten
thousand on labor then that's you know
that's a good investment uh and that's
the way you'd look at that piece of
machinery yeah you don't want this just
to be a wet finger in the air saying i
think this is gonna be a good idea do
the math on paper and go hey this is
going to save us this much per hour that
we would have paid an employee and we
can create this much more product and
working products because of this make it
a very logical factual thing i'm forever
telling our entree leadership audience
don't
rationalize
the purchase of stuff
by using your business and
calling it a business expense or calling
it a tax write-off
and
you know the world's worst is i grew up
in the real estate construction business
and you know you got a guy making
nothing and he drives up on the
construction site in a freaking 60
thousand dollar pickup truck
because he saw a silverado running
through a mud puddle on a chevy
commercial
and felt like he had to have one
and that's just dumber than a rock
um because as soon as you park that
sixty thousand dollar pickup on a
construction site some [ __ ] and a
bobcat's gonna back into it
and leave a nice dent in the side of it
and he works for you by the way so i
mean this is how life works so you know
you know the richest guy on the
construction site is is the guy with the
cheapest most beat up pickup
that's the richest guy on the
construction site because he don't care
what you think
and he's there to make money and he's
there to run a business and that's the
one that man i i'll never put i pulled
up a guy
uh
drove up and i swear to god i don't know
how this truck was actually held
together it looked like a
bailing wiring duct tape hold it
patching the thing together
it was probably a hundred dollar pickup
wow
and i'm talking to the old boy and he's
like he's he's laying bricks over here
and i'm talking to him and then the more
i talked to him i realized all the
entire crew there laying bricks and
there was about 30 of them
uh it's a big job uh worked for him
he owned the company the bricklaying
company and had the worst truck on the
site and they're all driving nicer cars
than him yeah yeah and with payments
yeah so that's the thing you want to
avoid is that kind of mentality when
you're in business construction or
otherwise either any business you can
pick on any business if you want to i
can i can talk to you about lawyers that
are stupid in their business and doctors
that are stupid in their business you
don't have to be a bricklayer to be
stupid um there's lots of stupid out
there to go around and i've done plenty
of it myself so you just have to really
dial back in and go okay well you want
to buy
flowers for the whole office well that's
great
and that and that'd be nice and they'd
smell good and they look good so are we
gonna have a boost in morale equal to
the cost of these this floral
arrangements or you know or is this an
expense we can just survive
well that what's the point in that yeah
you know and a lot of people do it on
credit cards and they go well i'm a
business owner i get great points i get
great rewards i never pay for flights
that's asinine
james is with us in dayton ohio hi james
how are you
i'm fine thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
well i'm 62 and a half i'm raising two
boys they're uh 11 and 15
fifth grade ninth grade
i'm going to be officially retired end
of the month um i owe about
about 19k on my house
and i really haven't done much for their
college i've only had them about five
years
um and i just got enough cash flow in
the last year and a half to where i
could start putting some money away did
you say 62 or 52
62 62
right okay all right so i'm wondering
i've got some investments and i'm
wondering if i ought to just take some
money out of there and pay that house
off yes and then i was thinking if i did
that i could just start hitting that
five you know the college plan thing
with the state farm
uh yes and no okay so yes i'm gonna take
the money out of the investments and pay
off the house but no we're not doing a
college plan with state farm you don't
do any investment
state the state oh no you don't do this
you don't do you don't do prepaid
college no we don't do prepaid college
you need to do it you can do a 529 where
you can invest the money in a good good
growth stock mutual fund and get in
touch with one of our smartvestor pros
to help you that and then also gear up
your retirement
yeah and this is a good question dave
that we get a lot on the show people
saying should i cash out my investments
and it's there's a pretty easy filter if
it's retirement do not touch it well it
is if you're over 62 there's no penalty
yeah so he can take the money out
regardless yes hopefully he's set for
retirement even if he's not it's 19 000
bucks get it done won't set him back too
much
if all you got is 19 000 you got other
problems that's true so um we got some
other stuff to catch up on so yeah just
take take the money out of the
retirement we wouldn't do that if he was
prior to 59 and a half because he had a
penalty
but um but right now are we you know
it's a big mortgage we start talking
about how much of this 150 000. how much
we're cashing out yeah but um you know
but if it's 19 just pay it off yeah and
then let's completely focus on
retirement savings and college savings
retirement savings and college savings
sit down with your smart vester pro
click smartvestor ramseysolutions.com
get that started and here we'll go
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books thank you to george
campbell to james childs kelly daniel in
the booth i am dave ramsey your host and
we'll be back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones as we talk to
you about your life your work your
relationships and your money it's a free
call triple eight eight two five five
two two
five kevin is with us in indianapolis hi
kevin welcome to the ramsay show
good afternoon sir it's pleasure to talk
to you you too what's up
uh i wanted to ask what your thoughts
are and maybe pros and cons of uh
in order to
kind of expedite step number two uh
allowing my credit card debt to go into
collections to
uh hopefully settle for
a far lesser number
i would not do that unless you simply
have not got a way to pay the bill how
much credit card debt have you got
it's not astronomical uh it's about 14
000.
um it is
something i can feasibly pay off it's
just in order to do it comfortably and
still be able to put some money in
savings it's gonna
it's just gonna take a lot longer than
well then
i would like be honest
so we work with folks that are on the
verge of bankruptcy all the time
and they have no money and a hundred
thousand dollars in credit card debt and
there's no chance
that they're going to pay the bill that
they legitimately owe
if it goes into default then we show
them how to
settle that debt because it's their only
option
we do not do that
as a method of
getting out of debt more efficiently
because we believe that you owe the
money
you borrowed the money and you have the
ability to pay the money and you should
pay your bill
if there's any way you can and that's
your case
so no you should get six extra jobs and
pay this crap off by friday
it's only fourteen thousand dollars how
much do you make
uh about sixty yeah and you're only
working forty hours
well i'm only getting paid for 40 hours
um
i i would gladly take an extra job uh my
my work schedule is is a little uh
cramped uh
to allow for an extra job but but like i
said i mean it is it is an amount that i
can pay off it's just gonna and you
shouldn't
and you should you should sell some
stuff you should find some work that you
can do you can turn uber on and off you
can turn you can get really flexible
schedules delivering pizzas you can
talk to your boss about getting paid for
the overtime instead of not getting paid
for the overtime that you're working on
you you can do a have a garage sale
you've got days off you've got time
you're sitting in front of stupid
television go make some money it's only
14 000 and pay it back don't sacrifice
your integrity for that
and i kind of want you to be in pain
kevin just a little bit i want you to
feel the sacrifice because if not if
this feels like a shortcut and you go
man i negotiated it down got that paid
off let's do that again and you're back
on the ride and you're back in a cycle
of debt i want you to have an ever again
moment and that's going to come from
taking a second job selling everything
going man never again am i going to be
in that space tighten up the old budget
the belt
big time big time that's simple
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five cody's in
cleveland ohio hi cody how are you
good how you doing better than i deserve
what's
up all right so uh i'm a new listener i
just found you guys today um basically
just as
in 26 i've pretty much lived
paycheck to paycheck my whole life uh
and
uh looking at you're hearing you guys's
channel so far this morning it's given
me some kind of ideas to finally get me
out of this first time i've actually
seen like a way out
so i've got
i've got a total of
42 000 in debt right now it's just me i
have a fiance but hers is only 2 000 in
credit cards i can take care of that
that's not something i'm really worried
about
um
so i have
the only real cost i have is credit
cards and auto loans
so my question is
this morning i got the idea of checking
the value on my i have a cheap compass
i've been paying off for a long time the
payment was 600 a month
for a while because i brought over
negative equity
i got that
drawn out longer to lower the payment so
i could
pay more off um that vehicle
had issues it's been six cents but i had
to get another vehicle when i did that
so i have two vehicles on loan
so my thought process was i'm only about
two grand off from what the
dealer will give me
for the vehicle and paying it off
totally so
i'm currently i'm on unemployment this
is the first time i've been unemployed
in my life um
so
i'm going to start door dashing right
now until i find something else to
be more steady in income she makes about
20 000 a year right now 1700 a month she
works as an sr
and housekeeping how old are you
i'm 26. cool
welcome to the show brother yeah so what
were you doing before before you were
unemployed
um well for a long time i was working uh
in the prison systems uh making decent
money but not making
good financial decisions so you know i
have a lot of stuff but i don't have a
lot to you know have a lot to show for
it yeah and uh well your a1
i want you to get income in the door and
that might mean doing door dash
instacart ship maybe you do them all do
whatever you can right now until you can
get a full-time salaried position or
something where you have some more
stable income coming in and what we
teach here is the baby steps i know
you're a new listener and so what we're
gonna do is do do you have a thousand
dollars in cash right now in savings no
no so that's your a1 that's your first
goal and get rid of that stupid car you
said you got the extra car you have two
cars right now both have loans on it
yeah could you sell both and get a
crappy car right now while you clean up
this mess
yeah that's what i i originally planned
on trying to get rid of the jeep no
matter what but i've been watching all
day and just thinking and
roughly on the
jeep and i can get what do you owe on
the other car
the other car oh 14. yeah
okay get you a five thousand dollar car
i just got the other one i don't know
though so i think i can get
a good value out of it hopefully good
yeah i don't care because here's the
thing these things are if you didn't
have these two car payments you'd have
like what's known as a life
yeah i'd have a lot of money left over
yeah and you could go get the job and
you start cooking cooking with gas then
you could get this thing moving and walk
right up those baby steps yeah here's
what i'm going to do kelly's going to
pick up we're going to send you a copy
of the total money makeover since you're
new to the show read through that get
really intense about this man and call
us back when you're debt free
[Music]
so
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today most people know me as the
guy who says get out of debt the guy who
did a lot of stupid things myself in my
20s lost everything had to start again
that's all true
but here's what's interesting in
developing the baby steps it's how i
became a millionaire the second time
and following those and now after 30
years of teaching this since going broke
i meet
tens of thousands of millionaires around
america that have become millionaires
by getting out of debt
and starting their investment program
using the baby steps process they are
what we call baby steps millionaires so
i haven't done a book in eight years but
i thought it was time
so i thought we're going to do a book
called baby steps millionaires because
i'm meeting babysits millionaires
everywhere and i want to show you that
it can be done
uh too many people out there telling
people it can't be done
and i know that it can be done and not
only am i going to show you i'm going to
prove it to you
with data with math with stories with
the largest study of millionaires ever
done so the new book is called baby
steps millionaires it's on pre-order
right now it comes out in two weeks uh
uh just a little over two weeks january
the 11th
and but you need to pre-order it before
it comes out that way you get the 150
worth of goodies that go with the
pre-order it's only 20 to pre-order baby
steps millionaires you'll also get
babysit's millionaire's audio book and
e-book the legacy journey audio book and
ebook you'll get tickets to the live
stream event that george and rachel and
i are doing the ramsey smart tax online
federal filing for free and the ramsey
plus free trial for 30 days an extended
free trial all of that about 150 value
just go to ramseysolutions.com
baby steps millionaires
we've already sold
tens of thousands the thing is selling i
was eating lunch with our book uh
wholesale book guy today who just sat
down at his table and he's like uh yeah
target just ordered this many and more
wow they'd ordered a batch to start with
but they're already seeing the sales are
so hot and amazon just ordered another
uh
you know a bunch and you come just quote
the numbers but they're just crazy and
uh because they're they've got the
algorithm they can tell what they're
selling already in pre-sale on what it's
going to do
and barnes and noah will just place
another order so and these are second
orders and the book hasn't even come out
yet because they're just seeing the act
that votes well seeing the activity
around it so i think we're going to be
okay with this i think so too this this
message is just something people have
been hungry for
as they search how do i build wealth
i wish it was out for christmas because
some of y'all are going to see your
stupid brother-in-law who thinks you
can't be a millionaire in america and
you want to prove to him you can be
and you know because he votes wrong and
everything and so you need to you know
you want to give him this book and go
yes you can and here's the freaking
proof shut up it'll help stop that
argument yeah it stops the argument but
um
of course that probably won't work but i
you should be nice to your stupid
brother-in-law it shouldn't be mean to
them first the first rule maybe don't
call him stupid to his face yeah maybe
just let dave do that well i mean you
know everybody's laughing because y'all
think that right miss merry christmas
you know gali all right
patrick's with us in san francisco
merry christmas patrick what's up
hey merry christmas dave pleasure to
talk to you again um my question is a
baby step by question and it's along the
lines of it it's stupid to do something
just for the tax benefit but if you get
the tax benefit out of it
you know it that's an extra bonus um my
girlfriend is very big on putting her
kids through private education
and what she was thinking is set up a
529 you can take out ten thousand
dollars a year
for private education yeah you know as
their miners yeah um
and then the money she puts in
would basically be a tax deduction and
am i missing something it's not a tax
it's not tax deductible
it's after tax dollars that go into a
529 the only benefit of the 529 is it
grows
tax-free
so running it through there running it
through there does not create a tax
deduction
unless unless unless it does on
california state tax now it doesn't on
the federal level
i don't know anything about california
law but but on the on the federal level
it's not a fed is not a deduction in
your federal income tax it does grow
tax-free so she dumps a bunch of money
in there and it grows it's the growth
that's tax-free that matters so if
you're doing this on the short term like
for two years or something or one year
it doesn't yeah i wouldn't even fool
with it
oh no she she's planning long term and
all the way through college i mean if
you've got a
brand new baby and you're thinking you
know when they're in the fourth grade
i'm gonna use some of this money then
yeah i'd use a 529 because the growth
will be tax-free
okay okay very good um and then um
actually if you if i could get a lesson
from you'd be um greatly appreciated um
i saw an instagram where you say just
put money into mutual funds don't bother
with etfs or anything and i was just
wondering what's the difference between
like an s p 500 mutual fund and an s p
500 etf
either one's fine
the other one's fine okay i use an i
just use a no load mutual fund uh but
convenient out of convenience i've had
that account open with that particular
company for a bazillion years but an etf
is fine what you don't want to get what
i don't endorse i'm not against etfs and
i'm not against index funds
we're not at ramsey what we are against
is saying that that is where you ought
to put all your money because you can't
buy mutual funds that outperform them
with your long-term retirement investing
and you can so that's a false narrative
okay so there are mutual you know there
are mutual funds that outperform the
indexes right
yes and my roth ira that's what i've
gone for is just track records over but
like for instance in my life i don't you
know i i'm
inside baseball okay i you know when i'm
when i've got extra money like if i get
a big check from a publisher i don't
need the money what am i gonna do with
it well i'm gonna park it in an index
fund or i could park in an etf i just
don't have one open but they're
basically the same stinking thing for
these purposes and i'll let it sit in
that s p 500 and keep throwing a little
bit of money in there and another little
check in there another check in there
and then i'll pull the money out a year
and a half two years later and go buy
real estate with it
so i'm not anti-index funds so it's a
really good way to g really good
efficient way to do some kind of
short-term game like that in particular
because if i leave alone a year my gains
are at capital gains rate not ordinary
income rate and i've got the money
earning more than sitting in a stupid
money market account right
hypothetically it should be
and um it's just real convenient really
easy to do it but as far as what i get
uh where i get banged around in these
stupid threads that don't even know what
i teach
is that you know i hate
etf efts i don't
we don't i mean we're not against index
funds what we are against is the the
thought train that's out there that you
cannot buy mutual funds that outperform
them so you shouldn't bother
in your long term and that's just simply
factually wrong and my mutual i've got
mutual funds mixes in my 401k that
outperform the indexes
and i've got them in other investments
for the long term hold that outperform
the indexes but the indexes aren't bad
they're just not the best for a
long-term play yeah and i you know with
your message it's funny people like to
have this argument back and forth but
the thing that you want them to do is
just invest something with a long-term
track record and if it's an index and
you think it's going to do one percent
upper whatever it is we want you to be
investing for the long term and right
now people are investing in nfts and
crypto and all kinds of crazy things
that don't have a proven track record
and so it's kind of like the people that
are having the argument they're gonna be
fine they're gonna do okay we're more
worried about the people who aren't
investing at all or in investing in
single stocks and super risky volatile
investments well and
you know what what etfs are primarily
used for jumping in and out of it's more
day trading people trying to time the
market and by most people and you know
timing the market there is zero research
that indicates that a buy hold or then
it doesn't beat a time a market time
process there's not a market timing
process that works
um you could come up with it not versus
being a multi-billionaire well i would
sell it i'd show you the software to do
it like these goobers that these get
rich quick things they sell you a piece
of software that's 4 000 bucks and
that'll time the market you're supposed
to you know based on this you should
jump in or based on that you should jump
out and yeah if that worked you think
they'd be selling on the back table of a
get rich quick seminar now billion
dollar mutual funds will be using that
system dummy
i mean come on
use your brain
but no
i've got the cluck of this figured out
because i met a guy in the back of the
ballroom at the ramada inn they still
have those oh
no they don't have ballrooms or they're
not in anymore
[Laughter]
ramada hands
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to five hundred dollars
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today travis and laura are in
austin texas says on my screen you guys
are debt-free congratulations
thanks dave well done how much have you
paid off
we paid off 186
797 dollars excellent how long did that
take
it took us about 46 months good for you
and your range of income during that
time well we started about 76 000 and uh
ending at 190.
there's a nice jump in four years
what do you guys do for a living
uh laura's an rn and i'm a teacher
okay
one of you not working at the start of
that now both of you are is that what
happened
uh well no i was actually uh coaching uh
in small college and i just got done
being a graduate assistant
then i made a career change and started
uh teaching and coaching in high school
and laura's picked up uh an extra job
along the way she teaches
uh nursing on the side and just a bunch
of overtime oh my goodness so y'all just
been working your butts off okay yeah so
what was the 187 000 in debt what kind
of debt
it was about 115 000 in student loans uh
36 on the car had some medical and
furniture then we cash flowed her
doctoral degree whoa
dr laura
yes way to go very cool congratulations
thank you very nice
so uh
wow you guys have you've accomplished a
lot in 46 months tell us your story what
started all this
so actually about five years ago my
in-laws started listening to your show
and they were very inspired and started
talking to us about your program and we
bought them fpu for their birthday
and when we did that they started the
program and when they were done they
actually regifted it back to us
and said okay it's your turn and it took
us a little while we we were pretty
davish for a while and then we kind of
just got tired of living month to month
and our money just leaving and not
knowing where it's going or what we're
doing with it and we just decided to go
gazelle intense about 36 months months
ago and we've done it and we're excited
about it wow so let me get this straight
they were into the ramsay stuff and you
went this will be a fun birthday gift
let's gift them fpu but you aren't doing
the stuff and then they go hey this is
amazing here you go regis so we actually
paid for their program on our credit
card and gave it to them for their
birthday oh my gosh well that's a big
fan you know that yep
the cops are outside your door right now
oh my gosh that's a great story that is
the best re-gift that's the only one i
think is appropriate is re-gifting fpu
because it changed their life way to go
guys way to go so how old are you
31. wow how does it feel to be free
it's pretty pretty relaxing and
inspiring we're really excited about it
and what we can start doing here in the
future has been just motivating us along
the way
sounds like the dog's excited too
oh you know that dog hasn't said
anything this whole time and then all of
a sudden they know dave ramsey's on
they're getting excited
there's that so you guys obviously uh
had the in-laws as cheerleaders anyone
else that was cheerleading you on
well we actually have four kids um we
started with two when we started the
program and then along the way we got a
surprise and had twins wow so they've
been pretty motivating for us
adorable
my parents been great with helping us
watch the kids and you know laura's
sisters and all of our family they've
been helping out along the way
very cool very cool you guys what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you did it
i mean really the key is setting a good
budget we use the every dollar app we've
we've finally gotten to a point where we
just know what it is and
but it was really monthly meetings the
two of us sitting down i'm the spender
travis is the saver so there were a few
heated conversations at the beginning
but we realized we knew what our goals
were and what we had to do to get there
and so really setting that budget weekly
meetings monthly meetings whatever we
needed to do and just putting faith in
each other putting faith in the program
wow you guys are incredible i mean there
wasn't a single thing that didn't change
for you guys in that four years so
i love this the heated conversation what
was the biggest money fight you had
while you're doing this whole thing
uh well i would just say right early on
when we uh started uh i struggled uh you
know you know being involved uh you know
and saying no just because i i was
making about twenty thousand dollars a
year uh my first my first year uh doing
it i didn't feel like i could really uh
participate that
and it took us a while to uh get get
that going uh for us to force us to work
what was the fight tell us about the
fight
dave loves a good fight no i can tell
you i mean there was a point where you
know i wanted to spend i did not want to
get rid of the credit cards and i was
like no i want the points i want to use
the points we're going on a cruise it's
going to be on our credit card it'll be
great and you know i could really tell
travis was not wanting to talk about it
and i was like we need to talk about
this i mean it was it was intense for us
and and we decided at that point like we
were done fighting about money and and
he you know i finally was like you know
if you don't feel like you make enough
money what are we going to do we have to
do it together we have to decide
together
and i think that's been the success of
it at all is every step along the way
it's you know it's not yours and mine
once we got married it's ours and how
can we get ours bigger and better to
where we want to go now we're getting
down to it way to go wow that'll preach
well done
very well done yeah when you when you
give up on the
philosophical lies that you were
believing that put you into the mess
like we're going on a cruise on our
points crap when you give up on that and
you actually lean into the truth which
is we're gonna have to bust it ourselves
and clean this mess up and quit doing
the stupid stuff that got us here that's
when it changed
i could hear that in your voice when
you're talking about it that's powerful
well done laura well done
good stuff
i love it yeah yeah
excellent excellent great job great job
guys you changed your family tree you're
freaking heroes man i'm so proud of you
guys go get a phd having babies pay off
a hundred and eighty seven thousand
dollars i mean that's impressive
very well done and you're on and you're
not you're just 30 years old man it's
just amazing
anything you freaking want to do you'll
be able to do including a cruise yeah
yeah which would be scarier than crud
right now
right well we'll be paying cash for it
that's for sure i'm not sure i won't be
trapped on a boat with that many people
anyway but right now i for sure don't
want to be trapped on a boat without
okay just well just do that now i just
lost the advertising on the cruise oh
well
um so yeah i lost that sponsor um
all right guys we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires coming your way early
uh before it hits the streets on january
the 11th how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth how you can do this
next chapter in your story you pay off
187 000 by time you're 31 ding ding
you're going to be multi freaking
millionaires before this is done this is
what's on the way for you send you a
copy total money makeover to give away
financial peace university every dollar
app you did it all you did what it took
to win i'm so so proud of you way to go
travis and laura austin texas 187 000
dollars paid off in 46 months making 76
to 190 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah even the dogs are barking life is
good man bust it man that's an
incredible couple hey they're power man
that's powerful nothing they can't do
that's power whew
you know the moral story there's a bunch
of morals of story but i love what he
said i didn't feel like because i was
only making 20 i had the right to speak
into this let me just tell you it's
called your life and you better speak
into your life
that's the lesson he learned you got to
speak up it doesn't you know well my
wife makes more than me my husband makes
more than me i don't feel like you know
my wife you know
our income is my income
so you think she doesn't get a vote well
by god i'll just promise you sharon
ramsey gets a vote okay
so uh we've run that thing a lot we run
it 40 years that way and we're not
running any other way it's not she
doesn't feel like she can speak up
because i quote earn the money unquote
that's what i love about sharon she's
not scared to voice her opinion she
she's not afraid i can tell you that so
but i tell you what that's how we got
where we are too you do speak up you
both step into it it's teamwork we both
have a voice who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack of gain
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay guys here's the reality the reality
is if you're going to lose weight it's
easier if you have a system
if you're going to get in shape it's
easier if you have a coach a personal
trainer
it's easier to have somebody walk with
you talk with you bust you
and so the last couple doing their debt
free scream said uh you know they gifted
it to their um in-laws and then they get
re-gifted it back so they go through
financial peace university they use the
every dollar app
the every dollar app is the world's best
budgeting app and i'm not exaggerating
because it's mine uh it just is
it's robust it's absolutely incredible
the premium version that you get with
ramsey plus when you sign up for
financial peace university and do the
whole thing is
connects to your bank and it
automatically downloads your debit card
stuff and you drop it right into your
budget and it's just really really
really easy
to keep your budget going with your
debit card transactions and so
um
you know
the best tools make it
easier
in any any sports you know i think of
sports you know a really good set of
golf clubs does change your game if you
have a decent game
if you're if you're i shoot a lot and
there's a difference in a cheap pistol
on an expensive pistol the the expensive
ones do shoot better there's a reason
they cost more you know i mean so you
get you know you the right tools help
and so every dollar helps going through
financial peace university learning the
stuff there's been uh
you know it's a close to 10 million
people now have gone through the class
over 7 000 families and so you can do
all of that and you know since we
started we started tracking it gosh a
bazillion years ago it used to be it
took 90 days to go through the class
when we taught it with like vhs tapes
and that kind of stuff right and uh the
average family would pay off 2700 or 50
300 in debt and save 2700 an 8 000
change in position during that 90 days
and you know what those numbers are
still just about the same we track them
all the time and
so you get about eight thousand dollar
movement in just the first three months
of doing this stuff
uh and so you know
since we don't charge eight thousand
dollars to go through the class that
makes the class a good buy you know and
uh at whatever 100 bucks good roi yeah
and if you want to try it out for free
you can do a free trial ramsey solutions
dot com slash fpu
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu get
into financial peace university run the
free trial start using every dollar
premium version you're gonna see the
difference it makes a difference it
really does greg is with us in maryland
hi greg welcome to the ramsey show
hey thanks for having me uh just was
scrolling through the radio first time
listener
and i was like man this guy just kind of
jives he makes sense so i'm calling i
need some advice
what i have going on is i uh recently
have tried to downsize and do everything
i can
going from a car loan to a small honda
civic
late model with
you know tens of thousands of tens of
thousands of miles on it so and no
payments
what i'm trying to do though is clear
debt
with my home it's the only thing left i
owe
uh on but it's 250 000 dollars
and i'm trying to figure out long term
is it better for me to invest the money
that i've cleared up with
paying off my car loan and credit credit
cards and use that money towards paying
on my home loan or do i invest that more
to my retirement at work
it's a great question and uh welcome to
the show thank you appreciate you
listening in uh so the process that we
teach on the show is called the baby
steps and it's the proven plan that dave
was just talking about with financial
peace this is the plan inside a
financial piece and so baby step one
thousand dollar starter emergency fund
baby step two clear all of your consumer
debt using the debt snowball sounds like
you're done with consumer debt right
right so baby step three is building up
a three to six months uh emergency fund
of expenses do you have that in place
i do not okay so that would be your next
step right now is to stack up that money
as fast as possible uh three to six
months if your income is really stable
uh you may lean three or if you want a
little more you can lean towards six and
once you're done with that you move on
to baby step four which is where we
start investing and the investing looks
like this
15 of your household income going into
retirement tax advantage retirement
accounts like a company 401k a roth ira
things of that nature then you move on
to college savings then you move on to
paying off the house so if you're saying
hey should i be investing more or paying
off the house right now once you've got
that emergency fund you're investing 15
then i would use any extra money to pay
off the house early once you've done
that you've got a paid for house you're
in baby step 7 and that's where you can
go hog wild you can invest like crazy
because you have all the income in the
world so that's the plan
yeah so it sounds like then investing at
15 once you meet that margin or that
barrier first
then move on to okay anything additional
is what you're going to use to do
additional principal payments on the
house exactly yeah exactly you got this
stuff man that was quick yeah you you
dialed it in fast that's exactly and
here's the reason okay
what we've run is we run over 30 years
of doing this we've run a bazillion
different actual life situations and
some hypothetical case study ideas and
said okay we're going to take someone
with this income at this age and here's
how to work this income at this age and
15 is a healthy amount but it doesn't
drain you down so far that you get to do
nothing on the house
um i mean you could have said it we ran
some scenarios at 20 back in the day
when we were developing this system we
ran some scenarios at 10
but the 10 percent the retirement was
too anemic and the 20
the amount of money we had to throw at
the house was too anemic anemic and so
it ended up landing to where you'll be a
multi-millionaire if you follow this
process exactly because you will have
built millions of dollars into your 401k
and you'll have paid for house and that
paid for house would be worth half a
million to a million and so um it sounds
like in your case anyway and so that's
that sets you up to do all of this all
of this is outlined in the book that we
did that's a number one best seller for
a decade it's on the best seller list
almost every week
it's called the total money makeover and
it's the baby steps on steroids it shows
you every nuance every question every
little detail about the baby steps what
to do next what to do next what to do
next and so on so hold on kelly i'll
pick up we'll give you a copy of that as
a new listener merry christmas we
appreciate you
joining us nick is with us nick is in
orange county hi nick welcome to the
ramsay show hi how are you dave
better than i deserve man what's up
um i have a question for you so i'm
still learning uh the baby steps that i
was referred to by some friends been
listening to you on youtube for a few
months and you know trying to match up
baby steps where we are
in our life and um so i've basically got
an emergency fund um that's probably
six to 12 months so i'm okay with that
my question relates to that so right now
i'm saving about
uh about 30 000 a year
partially going towards retirement
towards
that emergency fund and what we were
going to do was basically invest in a in
another home
right where my wife and i are thinking
of looking at another home to move to
so my question to you is right now out
of that 30 000 that's being saved
annually about 10 000 of that is going
towards my 401k at my work and 20k is
just going into a savings account
because we wanted it to be liquid for
the emergency fund
flash
have that ready when we want when we
want to pull the trigger on a home so i
wanted to ask you really two-part
question one was um
at this point we've got
a pretty decent amount saved up in there
now we've been doing this for a while
so i wanted to ask you should i now
change that 30k
allocation and make that
more towards the 401k
and very little
towards that savings okay the simplest
thing to do here if your phone our plan
the baby steps is do 15 of your
household income so that really
simplifies the numbers take 15 of what
you make in a year that so much should
be going into your 401k and iras
everything else you should not be adding
anything else to your emergency fund you
have too much in there now i'd scale it
back down to six and use the rest for
the house savings you need to separate
the house and the emergency fund they're
not the same fund
it's not a slash emergency fund slash
house fund it's have an emergency fund
in one account money market with three
to six months of expenses and everything
else is going over here for for the
house deal
and uh fifth everything above 15 you can
just pile it over there and even if you
want to back down the 15 a little bit
but i wouldn't i think you've done you
know you've got a bunch of money saved
here yeah so if you keep that up and if
this timeline is looking like hey we
need to get this house a year from now i
would not put it into the market into
mutual funds but if you're talking three
four five six years you may want to park
that in some mutual funds and let it
grow yeah or a portion of it anyway yeah
so very good stuff thank you for joining
us nick we appreciate you being with us
that puts this hour at the ramsey show
in the books good job to george campbell
to
james childs and to kelly daniel in the
booth i am dave ramsey your host and we
will be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsey show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host as we talk about your work your
relationships
your life and your money
right here every day and one of us
ramsey personalities can help you with
all of those things
uh some of us more than others but we're
all here to help it's uh that's for sure
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two five corey is in white
plains new york hi corey welcome to the
ramsey show
thank you so much for having me i
appreciate you taking my phone call sure
what's up
um thanks man thank you so much for
everything you do for everybody and help
change my family's life um i had a quick
question i heard you mentioned the other
day about uh
uh the the back door roth and it coming
to an end i believe you said maybe at
the end of this year and i wanted to
know if i um should try to convert a
traditional ira into
um a roth before the year is over
no you wouldn't do it by the way the
back door has not gone away because it
was part of the buildback better thing
and it didn't pass
so i just figured it was gonna pass so
um it may pass yet or some some version
of something may pass they're gonna i
mean the byte administration is gonna
plug this hole so i don't know whether
they're going to get done this year or
next year but just be looking for that
but you can do a backdoor roth and
that's different than
a roth rollover
okay yeah now when we would roll a roth
when will we roll a traditional to a
roth how much is in your traditional
um
it's only about thirty thousand okay so
you're gonna create a seven thousand
dollar tax bill
yes
okay
when would i create a seven thousand
dollar tax bill to convert to roth so it
grows tax-free
baby step seven
yeah are you in baby step seven
no i'm not i'm still in four five and
six i just again my concern was that
i was going to miss out on this and i
just wanted to know if there was
something i should or should do good
question no you're not gonna miss out on
it and two i'd rather you put the seven
thousand dollars towards your mortgage
yeah okay do you have are you what baby
step are you on right now four five six
four okay okay four five six yeah i'd
put that on the mortgage and once you're
at baby step seven hopefully it's still
around and you can uh convert it over
yeah that's so like it folks if you're
listening it means you got like a
hundred thousand bucks sitting in a
traditional rollover and you wanna move
it's gonna cost you 25 grand i don't
want you spending that 25 it's a good
move to do it if you're you know you're
in 30s or 40s 50s to move it and let it
grow from this point tax-free
uh is going to be beautiful and it has
the same mathematical effect of having
invested another 25 000 into your
ira or into your investments but
don't do that while you still got a
mortgage
don't do that while you've still got
other debt while you're earlier in the
baby steps your kids college isn't taken
care of i don't want to create a 25 bill
for you while you're still working the
baby steps
but once you're out there in baby step 7
it's it's a wonderful
thing to be able to do that so
good good good question
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five christopher's in
oklahoma city hi christopher how are you
hi i'm
pretty good i guess good how can we help
oh i have problems
um
well
so we had uh some fraudulent
transactions on our account and um
my wife was talking about getting a uh
a credit card uh
because she makes uh
online transactions and to i guess i i
guess they uh they're easy broad is
easier to handle
in on credit cards
um and uh i mean
i've watched you guys
yeah i've watched your youtube stuff all
the time uh for years
so i know i wanted to know what you
would recommend
to prevent fraud
um preferably something free
yeah
well fr fraud is uh has the if you
get a fraudulent transaction on a credit
card
you don't owe the money if you get a
fraudulent transaction on a debit card
you don't owe the money and so the net
result of both is no loss to you it's
both free
visa has the in mastercard have the
exact same protections for fraud on
debit as they do on credit now on your
debit it can come out of your account
and it made it be a little bit before
you get it put back into the account but
the bank is on the hook for that
transaction not you
so you do not have a greater risk
of losing money with a debit card than
you do with a credit card so that's just
bogus now here's the other thing if
she's bouncing around where she's
showing doing online crap where she's
showing up with fraud all the time
she needs to she needs to fix her dead
gum ways i mean what are you doing what
kind of sites are you hanging out on
that's crazy i'm not going to continue
to a behavior pattern that's inviting
fraud into anything
yeah i
don't think she's like
going crazy online i mean like this is
the first time we've noticed that well i
mean what how many different fraudulent
transactions were there
uh there were two
but they'd shut down them yesterday oh
my god that's just ridiculous you're
gonna completely change your whole way
of handling money over two fraudulent
transactions i had a fraudulent
transaction on my debit card last week
they shut it down removed it instantly
shut the card down for 48 hours reopen
we're done
i'm not gonna completely change my whole
life over two transactions you live in a
world where you're gonna have a
fraudulent transaction occasionally i
thought you were talking like you had a
hundred or something yeah she needs to
just make sure she's got the right
security measures in place when she's
shopping online don't store your card
info make sure you get secure passwords
don't use the same passwords across
sites this is basic if she really wants
security this is how she's going to get
it not from a credit card and so this is
going to be a conversation you have to
have with her it sounds more like a
marriage conversation than it is a
financial uh question but
she has to understand that has the same
protections you'll be okay there's even
sites like i use one called privacy.com
it makes fake debit card numbers that
are attached to your real account uh
james childs is a big fan of that and
that really protects you and you can set
a lot of different limits on there so if
she's really that concerned there's some
great tools out there but a credit card
is not the tool to go with
and two fraudulent transactions two of
anything shouldn't be enough to cause
you to completely change the way you
handle your money no people freak out it
sounds to me like she just wants a
credit card that's what it sounds like
and yeah and so that she can go into
debt and go do a bunch of other crap
with money y'all don't have that's what
it sounds the credit card is much more
dangerous for your financial future than
any chance of fraud on a debit card
that's the truth
mic drop all right ira is with us in
lexington ira how are you wait a minute
let me try that again i deserve dave how
are you doing sir just the same what's
up
so
my wife and i are
baby step seven um
we became debt free in 2019 and we're
saving up for
uh real estate investing and
i would like to ask you if you
rolled up in our shoes would you
form an llc or would you buy
um properties in cash personally
i'd go ahead and put it in an llc
just just for risk management and i
don't put more than five million dollars
of property into an llc after that i
form another one
and uh and so if i have a single
property that is more than five million
it has a standalone llc and that way if
something happens on that property they
can only sue for
and take that one property they don't
get everything else you own so it's a
risk management thing to separate your
risk
with an llc in real estate and i like
using them for that
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today welcome to ramsay show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five blinds.com
it gives us our question of the day they
have a 100 satisfaction guarantee means
even if you miss measure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey and you'll get
the best deal today's question comes
from jermaine in florida
why pay off collections if your credit
score debt and taking loans goes against
your teachings
i gotta read that one again
why pay off collections if your credit
score
debt and taking loans goes against your
teachings what is he asking there
well he's asking why pay off your
debt you know he does he's not if you're
not worried about your credit score and
just let it run up well it's not about
the credit score here
yeah so what amounts to is jermaine
you're picking and choosing which of our
teachings you like
in order to do something stupid so let
me help you the teaching number one is
the number one correlating character
quality to people who build wealth is
extreme levels of integrity
you're not representing that in your
question very well
so integrity says if you have debt in
collections that you go
settle it if you're broke you offer them
a settlement of some kind and we teach
people how to do that regularly or a
settlement if the
uh fees and other things added to it are
unreasonable and out of control crazy
like double triple quadruple that kind
of thing
um but
you know you got a 250 medical bill
there where you actually went to the
doctor and you did a 250 dollars you
need to just pay your bill jermaine
that's why
yeah this does not go against our
teachings to pay off your debt that is
in fact what we teach uh and we're not
concerned about the credit score nowhere
do we say pay off collections so that
your credit score doesn't take a dip uh
we we are not concerned with that but
like dave saying it's the integrity
factor here you took out this debt we
believe you should pay it back
it does help your credit score though
sure because the collection's standing
against your credit score but if you're
not worried about your credit score
because you don't borrow money anymore
per our teachings then his point is why
bother and pay them off why go clean it
up because you owe the money
and because it's your electronic
reputation and you need to spend some
effort
um and a bad credit score can hurt you
in certain situations so we like no
score and that's what happens when you
pay off all of your debt but with it
sitting in collections out there
that's not going to be a pretty
situation if for some reason they needed
to pull that score and they go
no you're not going to get no score is
preferable uh bad score you can live
with if you never try to borrow money or
never try to do anything where they're
pulling your credit score but um
i'm not trying to get you off the grid
um i'm just trying to get you where
you're not dependent on debt as your
source
that's the thing and so that's where you
misunderstood and
again i think you're picking and
choosing which of our
teachings because we've always taught
people to pay their bills
if at all possible if you have the money
if you can find the money if you can
work extra if you can sell stuff pay
your bills we want you to pay your bills
because that's what's best for you in
the long run
and again the number one correlating
character quality of people that are
able to build wealth and win is extreme
fanatical levels of integrity
so that's what you're you know that's
what you're aiming for
nikita is with us in boston hi nikita
how are you
i'm doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
uh i have what may be a fairly simple
question and that is
how to best allocate money um after
you've maxed out your 401
so
for a little bit of context um i just
got a pretty massive increase in income
um and making about 200k a year awesome
way to go yeah
uh
i don't have any debt besides about 20k
in a car payment
um
and i have about 70k already saved
good is 70k in what
uh it's a mix of things it's uh
some i mean most of it is in a mix of an
ira and richard ross do you have any
money saved that is not in retirement
yes yeah i have um about three months
emergency high interest savings account
how much 15k 16k all right
so um
here's the thing nikita
i know it's not a fun answer but you're
not ready to invest right now until we
clean up this debt
how quickly could you payment
you said you had 20k on something else
on a car
just the car okay
so i mean you can do it nikita's way
that's fine uh but if you want to do it
the ramsey way what we teach is that
you're going to have a thousand dollar
starter emergency fund and any other
money uh is going to go towards debt
this is not in a retirement account let
me clean this up real quick with your
income i mean you're going to be there
really fast so i'm going to put 15 000
on your 20 000 car and pay the 5 000 off
in a month or two then i'm going to
build your emergency fund up to three to
six months of expenses which sounds more
like 15k in cash in your situation
then and only then would you restart
your 401k which you need to stop until
you've done those things
yeah i mean i can i mean realistically
uh my retirement account is pretty small
i actually have a much larger personal
investment like it's invested but not in
a retirement account
um so it's liquid
so
i mean i could i could pay the car
payment off in full today good do it um
but so then the question becomes
you know after that with the money i'm
making i'm also i'm single i'm young
um i can definitely max out the 401 very
comfortably mm-hmm
okay you're debt-free and you have i
thought you i thought you said you had
nothing except
sixteen thousand in an account plus your
retirement money
uh and so i have my my net worth right
now is that one no no stop stop stop
stop you're talking in circles all right
do you have money other than the 16 000
and other than retirement money
yes
what
i have 50k
in an investment account that's
non-retirement okay that wasn't what you
answered before all right good cash that
out enough of it and write a check and
pay off your car today
okay then we'll get on with your
question yeah you make sure you've got
three to six months of expenses 16 000
is not enough it's okay if you want to
call it that we'll call that your
emergency fund okay then you put 15 away
now you can do your maxed out 401k which
won't get you to 15
because 15 of 200 000 is thousand
dollars we're trying to get to so you
can put 19 in your 401k you can max out
your roth ira and you'll be just fine
doing those two things you're not going
to quite get to 15 do you own a home
no okay cool then then we start saving
like crazy to buy a house
and it's always
good to save for a house even if you're
not sure
you're gonna buy soon you are gonna buy
some day and it won't hurt you to have
300 000 bucks in an account when you get
ready
okay
so that's your next big goal beyond
maxing out a roth and maxing out your
401
yeah i don't think i can do oh raw you
can do a back door roth
oh back door right yeah yeah
and so
jump in with your smartvestor pro and
get that started but pay off that car
today girl don't walk around acting like
this car is okay
because i don't i didn't i don't smell
you paying it off i think you think it's
like it's no big deal i can eat 17
donuts and i won't get fat yes you will
17 donuts equals fat i know i did it
okay so you can't do that
i got as big as a dadgum house during
covid because i ate every donut and a
50-mile radius but if you just if you
act like that that's what's gonna happen
and so you just can't you can't
misbehave and and just gloss over it and
act like nothing's going to happen
there's a result to your behaviors pay
off the stupid car and don't buy another
stupid car unless you pay cash for it
you make too much money you make a lot
of money now girl you're doing so good
congratulations on the incredible raise
the incredible income yeah now let's
use it and go make some money with it
go make some wealth with it you're
already making money but let's build
some wealth with this thing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsay show
i'm dave ramsey in the ho in the hobby
hobby i'll be out here we go in the
lobby of ramsay solutions
it might be a hobby but it's a lobby and
on the debt-free stage is colin and
caitlin hi guys how are you hey better
than we deserve how you doing dave merry
christmas just the same brother merry
christmas to you where do you all live
just south of lexington kentucky oh not
a too bad a drive to nashville but
welcome good to have you thank you here
to do a debt free scream how much have
you paid off
156 580 i love it and how long did this
take
33 months wow and your range of income
during that time started out about 36
and got around 55 towards the end
you sold something we should do
okay it did more the map didn't work all
right
what was what kind of debt was the 157
000 and what did you sell a little bit
of everything uh we had credit cards a
lot of student loans i had a car payment
had some medical bills
um and uh what we sold was our home that
we had at the time oh
ouch
big sacrifice to make this move yes sir
okay and so how much equity came out of
the home
about 75 000
right okay and then so you cash flow the
other 75 yeah or 80. okay now that no
those numbers work so what are you doing
renting right now
well right now uh we were fortunate
enough that uh we had some great
grandparents that were really good about
money you talk about that all the time
this is this is stuff that they that
they knew and applied and so we were we
were beneficiary there was a vacant
farmhouse uh that my family owned and so
at the time
uh i went a job i got a job that where i
traveled and so it didn't matter where i
lived and so we got to
move up there after i finally convinced
her to uh kind of
get up and and get out we're originally
from uh just south of atlanta georgia oh
it was a big move
okay so you moved to the family farm the
free rent yes yes in the in the old
farmhouse um
so it's green acres you probably don't
even remember that song yeah that that
that sitcom
that's right and so yeah
and uh uh yeah and so you move her onto
the farm we got out of debt and uh was
it worth all that man that's a lot
absolutely absolutely yeah so you like
farm life then
definitely the traffic is so much better
hey all traffic is better than atlanta
yes it is
oh my god atlanta's cursed yes
yeah and lexington they don't even know
what traffic is compared to atlanta or
nowhere near lexington even yet wow
so that's a big move this was tell us
the story of how you processed all of
that that i mean it's literally a move
but i'm saying emotionally
you guys
you changed your whole way of looking at
life
yeah we did it was really hard at first
um it was hard on our family it was hard
on us just to
because it was such a big move and we
had
three kids at the time
but they were all very young so it
wasn't too too hard for them to adjust
to it
um but it is it has been hard to be away
from the grandparents and the aunts and
uncles but
um the
the financial benefits that we've
experienced have just been completely
worth it and it's not forever no right
but it for this it's for a stage to make
the turn here so like your parents are
in atlanta then yes yes all of our
parents are both of you okay but the
grandparents or the great-grandparents
are up in the lexington
well i've got some aunts and uncles
still in like i mean
the property you're on was your right
yeah okay your family yeah okay i
thought so wow wow okay so 33 months ago
like what was that turning point where
you guys said man we got credit cards
dropped into the house people don't just
up and change their whole life like that
what happened with you guys right well
um
we just didn't want to be slave to the
lender anymore like
you're taking the proverbs all the time
uh 22 7
that says the borrower is slave to the
lender and we want to have one master
and that's jesus
and so this is just the big thing that
we've been convicted about doing ever
since 2016 um we started an fpu class at
our church
at the time our shovel was more of a
spoon
and so we kind of dropped out of the
class because there was no way
that we could afford we felt like this
isn't for us i guess right we did but it
was always on our hearts and on our
minds and we just kept that
that burden on our backs of that weight
then we realized the
uh compounding interest
of the student loans and we were like we
just had a moment
in 2018 after he had gotten his new job
and we were like we just have to do it
now it's now or never
and so you bust it yeah did your fam
some of your family think you were crazy
oh yeah oh definitely they still think
we're crazy okay all right some of your
friends too yeah absolutely what church
were you going to with financial peace
university um it was first baptist
jonesboro yeah okay great yeah very cool
good okay so
now you're debt free a hundred percent
because you got rid of the mortgage yeah
and everything now we don't have a house
yet but we're 100 debt free and uh how's
that feel
that's such a burden lifted um you know
that there's a there's a future there's
a hope and a future now uh you know when
we think about our kids and just the
legacy that we want to live with them
there's there's there was a way out and
so we're just so grateful uh for the way
the lord provided that just just out of
the blue with the new job the the house
that happened to be vacant at the time
it was just you know providential to say
the least and uh we're we're just so
thankful
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
of course sticking with the budget but
for us
it's really more knowing your why
and of course our number one why is we
want to be
ready to do whatever the lord asks us to
do and we believe that the debt was you
know limiting that potentially and so we
wanted to to get rid of that master and
just have one master that's good and and
then of course our otherwise are sitting
out here with us um we want to just
change the family tree we want to leave
a legacy that
that just teaches them good financial
principles and and hopefully blesses
them and so we can continue to give to
others along the way
beautifully said i love it as a person
of faith it is amazing the doors i can
open when you have all the options in
the world because you're not chained to
debt and lenders so that's a powerful
thing and it sounds like it started for
you guys with a whole lot of conviction
and you went we should probably listen
to this there's probably something here
yes so when you were sitting back there
and you say okay proverbs 22 7 is real
i got a monkey on my back i got to get
them off
you had this vision in your mind of how
it was going to feel when you finally
did get there
was it as good or better than you
thought it was going to be or worse i
mean does is it is it like oh i thought
it was going to be better than this
i'd say it was better
better than we expected okay
so now when you get the next 200 000
cash
which you're on your way to get that'll
be your next thing right you got a big
pile of money what are you gonna do next
well uh we kind of had to go into stork
mode
uh we had planned to save up baby step
3b and save up a down payment on house
but we found out we're pregnant with
twins now baby boys
that's exciting yeah
of course you are
incredible what does that take a grand
total tuna how many kids will that be
six whoo
yeah okay you gotta get a new van
now you get the van you get the the
twins landed and then you're gonna buy a
house will you stay in lexington or will
you go back towards atlanta we don't
know god hasn't shown us yet okay
exactly where we're gonna land so you'll
be there for a little while longer yeah
saving up that's good it's it's a great
season of life you look back on this
section of your life as an adventure
when you change the whole direction of
everything
uh there's a sense that um that there's
a milestone there's a stake was driven
in the ground right here so very very
well done i'm proud of you guys you're
heroes you got to feel great we did it
way to go we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you comes out january
the 11th but we're going to give you an
early release copy because i know a guy
and i'll also give you a copy of total
money makeover and you can give that to
somebody and get them started on the
same kind of journey so let's get the
kiddos in and it's colin and caitlin
kara krista corbin and chloe all from
the lexington kentucky area plus two
little brothers on the way 157 000 paid
off in 33 months making 36-55
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
[Music]
touchdown look at that bunch oh my gosh
they're cute adorable
wow
this is the ramsay shop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day jeremiah 26 14
as for me i am in your hands
do with me whatever you think is good
and right
richard branson says train people well
enough so they can leave treat them well
enough so they don't want to
john's with us in austin texas hi john
welcome to the ramsey show merry
christmas
ah merry christmas to you as well
uh so i am following the baby steps uh i
just finished babysit once i have a
thousand dollars uh for an emergency
fund
and i have credit card debt left over
and also i have a car release which i
promise to you it's the last car release
i'll ever do but
uh i'm starting out because the
used car market is really good right now
so if i were to compare the kelly blue
book value of the car for the trade-in
compared to my buyout it would basically
net me a 4700 check
i was calling to see if i should
potentially do that or if i should
prioritize one of my lower credit cards
that i owe
it nets you money
it doesn't cost you money so how does it
compare to a credit card i'm confused
oh no uh i'm sorry i mean no you're
saying should i move it up in the dead
snowball because of you got to come out
of pocket with 4 700
no there uh it would i would end up
getting 4700 back so yeah kelly blue
book value is 19. yeah and you would you
would get rid of a car payment and have
5 000 in your pocket
and how does that
you should do that or do a credit card
i'm confused
i'm sorry uh so basically take that
amount and then i was wondering like is
that enough to get like a decent enough
used car oh yeah definitely okay yeah
get you a five thousand dollar car
okay that's a net that's a net zero that
costs you nothing towards your debt
snowball except it gets rid of your big
buck car payment
sure what do you make a year
uh about between 55 to 60k cool good
okay and how much debt do you have left
not counting this car
yeah not counting the lease so
uh credit card that's about 17 000 and i
have about a 5 000 personal loan that
i'm paying off
okay so 18k clears you
and how much is your car payment
uh car payment is 375.
okay cool all right so you got an extra
400 a month to throw towards the 18.
when do you project you'll be done with
the 18.
without a car
oh yeah without the car uh
i know everything i've done tattooing
has been including a car payment so i
mean
i mean if i did 375 extra a month that's
uh
yeah i don't know it would definitely
shorten you well that's five thousand
dollars a year
uh making making you said 55
uh yeah i'm 55 to 60 i do commission so
it varies i would want your debt free in
under a year
that's 1500 bucks a month
yeah
and you don't have the 375 car payment
that gets you there in a year
you can do that and then i guess
probably insurance payment would
probably go down too because i imagine
insurance on a uh lower-end car would
definitely go down significantly from
what i'm paying now yep
cool i guess that was an easy question
well it's a painful thing to do
but here's the thing
the way i answer these questions and the
way i look at it george is to say
okay
10 years from today which of these moves
am i going to be glad i did
am i going to be glad i drove a piece of
crap five thousand dollar car for two
years one year while i get out of debt
another year while i save up some money
finish my emergency fund and buy a
better car
um is that going to have led me towards
more wealth and more peace and more
prosperity or slogging my way through
this lease which one's going to have
done it and it's so for me it's a
no-brainer because doing it this way is
going to get you to wealthy faster
yeah
and it's in we're driving a piece of
crap for two years oh well give it a
name old blue
you know old big red right if you got a
car that needs a name you're probably
working their plan oh yeah and i was
just telling uh dave before before the
break about my crappy car that i'm
excited to upgrade uh now because we've
been aggressive on paying off the house
and so if you've got big goals like that
you're willing to do some things and
sacrifice and one of those is driving a
nice car you know i can live without
that for now
so with our last debt free scream george
for the year 2021 screaming on the air
now these are people who actually did
the on the air scream not other ways we
track in the lobby or on the phone just
on the lot in the lobby or on the phone
they made it to the show
54 million
three hundred or four hundred and thirty
four thousand and forty three dollars
wow
debt free streamers have paid off
in one year
54 million a year that's what four and a
half million or so i did that for 10
years i'd be half a billion and i've
been doing this show for 30 years so
we're well over a billion
worth of debt-free screams easy
uh during the time i've done this show
on the air
wow of people that have paid off their
debt and celebrated it on the air a
billion dollars in debt reduction and
that's just the ones that have made it
but dave ramsey doesn't know what he's
doing
so just in case you idiots on reddit
didn't understand right oh my god so
yeah this is just so insulting but the
uh yeah 54 million dollars paid off this
year
in debt free screams alone those people
think that george camel and the people
at ramsey solutions are geniuses
those people that have had their lives
changed and completely
moved around it's a big deal that's
incredible
that's a milestone to achieve and shout
out to kelly and everyone in the booth
who all helps make these happen because
it's a task to get all these scheduled
and get them on the air and man and i
can't imagine how many applications we
have so if you add up all of the people
who became debt free in a year who
didn't get to share their story i
guarantee it it'd be closer to a billion
yeah everyone's always billions and
billions that's incredible and billions
and billions and billions that's why we
do this it's inspiring billions like a
thousand million yeah
that's good math pretty amazing
tyler is in columbia south carolina hey
tyler welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help
so i have a question i recently got a
new job
um and
my fiance we lived together a recent got
engaged
and i make about 90 a year
and she is doing a paid externship
and she makes about 12 a year and she'll
graduate in may doing full-time
respiratory therapy at the hospital
um
when will you get married
uh november 19 2022 is the date
okay this coming november okay
yeah yes sir um
and my question is
i've recently been uh introduced to you
and i've got a thousand dollars in
savings
um
and i've got about 16 000
in credit card debt total
um
and i just in may bought a brand new
truck
so
i'm wondering should i i've got an offer
for the truck from one of the online
dealerships
room
they're
willing to give me 43 000 and i owe 45
on the truck
i can make the payment on the truck and
still have
money left over
to throw at the compounding debt uh ball
but i'm wondering should i
keep the truck and just blast the debt
like like normal smallest to largest
or should i give let vroom take it and
then drive an old beater that i have at
my um apartment it's a 99 f-150 you have
two cars it has a 99 f-150
i have a 99 f-150 with about 200 000 it
needs about a thousand dollars worth of
work i love that i wouldn't have
but i wouldn't have
the payment
of on on the new ticket how old are you
23.
i'm 26 she's 22. okay how much do you
make a year 90.
i make 90 now starting out yeah
uh if i woke up in your shoes sir i
would sell this truck in a heartbeat
okay so sell the truck and i would cry
when i sold it because it's a sweet
truck it is i love it it's my dream
truck man you know what it's a freaking
nightmare though it's not a dream
it is because here's the thing you found
you found what you really love and
you're marrying her
yes and it ain't trucks yes sir and the
fact that you guys are going to work
together both of you are going to have
you're going to have 200 000 of your
income in three years
and you will and you have no debt and
you'll be able to save up and buy
whatever you want to buy in cash because
you made this move
and so this is a move for your future
it's not a move for your present but
yeah i would sell it wouldn't you yeah
cash flow that wedding get out of debt
and start your marriage off right man
congratulations
and never never never never borrow on a
vehicle again if you want to be wealthy
wealthy people just don't do that
but you're a sharp young dude and that's
i'm going to cry when i sell it though
because it's sweet that puts this hour
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus hey guys this is
james senior producer for the ramsay
show did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week and
a lot of those people listen on one of
our 600 plus radio stations across the
country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you